The final solution is the cube root of 4xyz squared divided by 2x squared yz,
that's some great algebra work, if you got that one correct. Again, let's start
by thinking about what this denominator should look like in order for it to
simplify. We know we need the factors 2, x, y, and z to appear a multiple of
three times. This means, that we want to change to the 1 To 2 to the 3rd. We
want to change x to the 5th to x to the 6th, y squared to y cubed, and z to z
cubed. Notice how each of these powers is the next highest multiple of 3 for
these powers. So to change this denominator we'll multiply by the cubed root of
2 squared x y z squared. And since we multiplied this denominator by this
expression, we multiply the numerator by the same amount. Next we simplify the
numerator and the denominator. Our numerator can't be simplified so we just
rewrite 2 squared as 4. For our denominator, we take the cube root of each of
these factors. We use power divided by root to get 2 x squared yz. And here's
our final answer.